I already told you about some of the absolutely
seditious elements and insightful elements,
and by that I mean Iansiti not incite like,
oh, what great insight you have that Donald
Trump posted to social media yesterday, which
were quite rapidly removed by Twitter as well
as Facebook.
And that includes a video in which Donald
Trump says to his violent riot supporters,
go home.
We love you.
You're great.
It was stolen.
Obviously, this was what was going to happen,
implying that the violence was actually justified.
But it's time to go home.
Twitter and Facebook suspended Donald Trump
for an interim period as a result of the things
that he posted.
Donald Trump was suspended from Twitter and
Facebook for his tweets and videos to supporters
who were violently storming the U.S. Capitol.
Trump posted the social media message saying
he loves them and that they're just the best
people, but that it's time to go home.
He repeated false claims about election fraud
in those messages, and Twitter said that it
removed three tweets for so-called severe
violations of their civic integrity policy.
Now, earlier in the show, we already went
through what these three items were.
The first was a tweet in which Donald Trump
denounced his own vice president, Mike Pence.
That by itself is historic and outrageous
in nature.
And in so doing, he included in that tweet
that there was all sorts of fraud and pences
and doing the right thing.
That tweet was initially removed by Twitter
later in the day.
Donald, as the violence grew on the Capitol
at the Capitol, Donald Trump posted a one
minute video saying it was stolen.
We won in a landslide, but it's time to go
home.
That video was removed by Twitter.
And then later, Donald Trump posted another
tweet in which he essentially said, and here
I'm paraphrasing, we read the exact tweet
earlier.
This is what you get when you steal the election
that we won in a landslide.
Twitter also removing that.
And then before we knew it, Donald Trump had
been suspended for 12 hours on Twitter and
Twitter, also saying that Trump's account
will remain locked indefinitely if those tweets
are not removed, also indicating that future
violations of the Twitter rules by Donald
Trump will result in the permanent suspension
of this account.
So there is a micro story here and there is
a macro story here.
The micro story is we've been wondering after
January 20th comes and Donald Trump no longer
has what are called public public servant,
I believe it's called public servant protection
by Twitter.
Is he going to get banned very quickly?
And the reason that it's a micro story is
that it really depends on, for example, does
Trump even continue to tweet?
A lot of people email me.
They say, David, once Trump is no longer president,
all he's going to be doing is tweeting.
He's going to tweet even more.
He's going to need Twitter as the bully pulpit
because he's not going to have the bully pulpit
of the presidency.
Others believe that Donald Trump is being.
So I don't know what the right word is.
Disheartened.
It disheartened.
Almost sounds like the guy has normal emotions,
but that Donald Trump is going to basically
end up so defeated and shrunken by everything
that's taken place in the last few months
that we're just never going to hear from him
again once he is no longer president.
So, listen, Twitter is making it very clear
that if Trump continues this stuff when he's
no longer president, he's getting banned from
Twitter altogether.
He has about 80 something million followers
and Twitter saying we will ban him.
And that's that's interesting.
The bigger story here is that we have seen
such a debasement and coarsening of what is
acceptable to hear from our elected officials
that it has trickled down dramatically.
And now things that four years ago would have
been inconceivable from elected officials
are considered sort of normal because they're
not as crazy as what Donald Trump is doing.
And I'll explain what I mean by that.
Donald Trump is at the very peak of this completely
unhinged, unbecoming language and behavior
that we would expect to see from an American
president doing everything from inciting violent
riots, attacking everything from reporters
to his own vice president.
I won't give you the list because that would
take me hours to give you the list.
That is a new high watermark or low bar.
Call it what you want, but in the shadow of
what Donald Trump has made normal or to some
degree over the last four years, or at least
expected because he continues to do it, a
whole bunch of Republicans who in the past,
even through political disagreements, would
have said this is too much.
They now participate in either.
Tacitly defending or repeating and sound and
and signal boosting to some degree, much of
what Donald Trump has been saying, and we
really saw it come to a head yesterday where
only when these riots lead to our elected
officials needing to put on gas masks to be
evacuated from the House and Senate chambers,
only then did some of them.
Some of them, mind you say, you know what,
the sixth to our objections about so-called
voter fraud that aren't going anywhere.
We're we're going to drop it.
We have to come together.
The violence has to stop.
And and and so they also, compared to the
2015 standard, have completely debased themselves.
But in the shadow of Trump's more cartoonish
debasement, a lot of them are getting a pass.
And you're starting to see now and we'll have
some clips of this a little bit later.
You're starting to see so-called reasonable
Republicans start to put a dividing line in
the sand, saying the Trump stuff is over the
line.
But what Josh Holley has been saying and doing
is fine.
What Ted Cruz has been saying and doing is
fine.
And this goes back to something I talked to
you about in really in November of 2016, where
I said it is going to be a fight to prevent
hyper normalization for the next four years.
We are as humans, we are so adaptable that
crazy situations become normal and they start
to feel normal to some degree.
And to those of us who have been wearing masks
now in public for many, many months, it's
it starts to almost feel weird not to have
the mask.
And this is because humans, by our nature,
are very flexible and adaptable.
We need to make sure that the Ted Cruz's and
the Josh Holli's, by being five percent less
nuts than Trump, don't sort of get a pass
in any way.
And with you and with me, they aren't getting
that pass.
But there are lots of more centrist types
and folks who more casually pay attention
to politics who are sort of like, yeah, yeah,
yeah, Trump's over the line, but the Republican
Party otherwise is fine.
No, no, no.
The Republican Party and right wing media
have been off the wall insane for four years
at this point.
And we have to remember we have to remember
not to forget that as we get beyond Donald
Trump.